let's go to our old friend brody from
dallas uh brody please don't torpedo
today's session of calls
i'm gonna do my best david how's it
going man going well
awesome hey so um we're fighting the
good fight out here in texas we recently
had a huge fiasco in the primary
elections
we had a huge disparity we had about 850
democratic primary voters had their
mail-in ballots rejected and less than
10 republican primary voters had their
ballots rejected
one of the things we've
struggled with here is getting help from
dc and i know that there's
talk about joe manchin possibly carving
out some things for different voting
rights legislation what i wanted to know
is what do you see as the most viable
path
for states like texas to have protection
from dc or do you believe that it's just
gonna have to come from all the state
legislatures
and as a follow-up what would you like
to see happen
so the i don't i don't know
exactly what you're referring to in
texas so without knowing the dynamics of
it it's very hard to say specifically
what could address that so just with
that as a kind of disclaimer
i would love to see a new voting rights
act that restricts the things that
states can do
and allows for federal oversight i think
many states you know they with the
a couple years ago
states were sort of released from their
requirements to pre-clear changes i
think we need to be adding more
requirements in terms of changes that
states want to make
that would be the ideal thing i don't
know that that's going to happen and so
of course it would be great if states
did legislation on voting rights within
their own states but the problem is
republican-controlled states don't
really have any interest in doing that
so it's a very tough situation i don't
know what the answer is
then as a personal question
would you be willing like let's say
would you compromise at all if uh let's
say republicans in the gop in the senate
particularly
wanted to enact something would you as a
progressive and just you personally be
willing to acquiesce or agree
to maybe
including voter id
being required as a part of that so long
as it doesn't disenfranchise people
or do you believe that voting id is
something that should be non-negotiable
from the democrat and the progressive
side of things so
two-part answer and these are really you
know you know these are big topics right
so there's a lot of different
considerations
i am
very skeptical of voter id because it is
a transparently bad faith way for
republicans to disenfranchise people so
that's why i have such a problem with
voter id as proposed and implemented
that being said if there was a voting
rights package that did significant good
things and codified them into law
i'd be open to negotiating on voter id
provided i was satisfied that there
really is
you know it you it can't cost money to
get the documents you need to get the
voter id it can't require rural poor
people to drive to the state capitol in
order to get the documents they need to
get the vote ready like if i was really
satisfied that all of those things were
dealt with i'd be willing to negotiate
on voter id as part of a bigger voting
rights package the problem is in
practice we know it's just a bad faith
way to purge people from voter rolls and
prevent people from voting
absolutely well hey i'm glad to have
talked with you and i hope i lived up at
least moderately or mildly to the
expectations and it's a good speak to
you again and please encourage all your
voters like you always do to register
and go out and vote everyone must vote
brody thank you so much for the call
let's take a quick break but we're going
right back to the phones in a moment so
if you still want to talk to me after
hearing all of these calls if you still
want to talk to me just hang on
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcasts too
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below